let's talk about some amazing benefits
of simply taking a hot bath
and i'm talking about temperature 40
degrees celsius or a 104 degree
fahrenheit for 30 minutes the biggest
benefit
is anxiety and depression there's
several studies that i'm going to put
down below that
back this up but if you have anxiety or
depression
this simple thing can greatly help you
and that is because number one it's
going to lower
cortisol cortisol is a stress hormone
less stress less anxiety
number two higher levels of serotonin
serotonin is the happy hormone
it's a hormone that helps you feel calm
it gives you a sense of well-being
and if you have that you're gonna have
less anxiety and definitely
less depression number three it's gonna
improve your sleep you're gonna get a
much deeper sleep
so what happens is this heat actually
relaxes you
so when you sleep your melatonin
actually causes your body to get a
little cooler
and so by raising the heat before you go
to bed
you get a rebound effect or a resetting
effect
and you actually become a little colder
and your body will get a much better
sleep
when it's on the colder side try to
sleep when you have a hot flash
it doesn't work right all right number
four your muscles are going to feel very
relaxed
one thing that i recommend is taking
epsom salts
magnesium to your bath and
lemon balm oil which is very very
relaxing and calming
people take this as a t or a supplement
it will help you decrease
chronic pain and stiffness now one
contraindication would be if you have
acute pain
let's say you're in a recent injury and
you have swelling
taking a hot bath might not be the best
thing to do you want to put
cold on that injury like a cold pack ice
would be best
but for chronic pain stiffness great
you're gonna have more flexibility
number six it can help you lower your
blood pressure
because it increases nitric oxide which
actually is a vasodilator
now on the flip side if you have heart
pain like angina pain or chest pain
not a good idea to take a hot bath and
one more contraindication if you
if you get lightheaded easily and you
take this hot bath right
and let's say for example the heat
increases all the circulation you have
blood in the muscles
and then you stand up and you get really
dizzy because you don't
your body isn't adapting to that that
well so you don't want to be fainting
and then
injure yourself number seven it has the
ability to potentially help stabilize
your
insulin levels i found some interesting
research on that i put a link down below
and number eight it can enhance your
immunity
because you're in inducing a fever if
you have an infection
a viral infection or even a bacterial
infection
and you keep your body really really
warm to the point where you're sweating
or you take a hot bath
you're going to help kill off pathogens
so inducing a fever is a very good thing
and then you climb in bed and you
wear a lot of clothes and you just sweat
all right there you have it the eight
benefits of a hot bath
a decrease in anxiety and depression
being number one
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course
will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today